story that affects every American when
you a friend or a loved one goes to the
doctor do you know how good your doctor
is these story seems to come right out
of a medical TV drama doctors operate on
the wrong body part or the wrong patient
gets the wrong medicine but these errors
are becoming a scary reality in America
the medical journal BMJ says medical
error kills more than 250,000 Americans
every year medical error is now third
the third leading cause of deaths in the
United States so the medical errors and
hospitals and other healthcare
facilities are incredibly common and may
now be the third leading cause of death
in the United States welcome back to the
deme show we got a double treat for you
guys Jim Marlowe Sheikh Mustafa now if
you guys don't know if you haven't
already sick and tired of being sick and
tired we had you talking about your
history for those that don't know dr.
Mercola you were his you were the chief
nutrition Nicholas optimal Wellness
Center from 2000 to 2007 helping people
and optimal health and because of he
because of the popularity of his website
during that period we were probably the
busiest nutrition based health center in
the country certainly one of the busiest
and had a lot of experience helping
people to improve their health through
nutrition now you're one of the movers
and shakers in the community people come
to you they say look shake should we do
this with our families should we what's
with the c-section many health issues
I'm having named some of the things that
that people are their concerns and they
come to you for advice and you gotta
give them advice
yeah people want to know I mean people
Muslims ask me all the time in the
community and even general people what's
going on with the birthing industry you
know should we consider alternative
forms of you know home birthing our
c-sections becoming you know just
routine is it something that we need
what do we do with vaccinations the
vaccination schedule seems very long
we're not really encouraged by our
medical practitioners to eat nutrition
this
really not to have much focus on on
health to just kind of just go to the
doctor should we take all these pills
should we do medical marijuana we get
all these sorts of questions I think
this is extremely important I want I
mean personally all the all the other
movers and shakers in the community what
are some of them some of them that are
out there that you're very close friends
well you guys have the MJ conference
that comes together yeah and you guys
decide these things is it so many of the
Yasir Qadhi is almost a lemma well what
are some names are out there yeah
there's Imam Suraj she comes a Yusef
Sheikh yes sir call the Imams a check
here they get the same types of
questions ready I'm sure they get they
definitely get the same types of
questions we got the fit Council of
North America we got um we got different
scholars councils and people are going
to them as like a source for kind of
getting getting some more information on
these issues and they want to know what
is Islam say about this right where do
you like what kind of guidance does
Islam give you and what should Muslims
be doing as good Muslims and we know
that we're you guys are specializing
also in protecting humanity and helping
humanity and you know delivering the
message of the purpose of life
protecting people from the spiritual
toxins that are out there but nowadays
Jim can testify there are so many health
toxins 50% of people living today will
have cancer 1/3 will die from it almost
70% of people are obese overweight
skyrocketing rates of heart disease
obesity diabetes so this is something
that definitely I usually mention that
hey all that wonderful work you're doing
it's going to get shut down if your
health gets shut down and do we have it
wrong here because a lot of times we'll
say okay go see the you know the expert
you know the guy in the white coat see
he knows best but we're seeing some
things that sometimes you know there's a
conflict here some things that that he
had mentioned that people aren't taking
the matter of nutrition seriously from
their regular doctors some are saying
okay you know they don't don't they have
a lack of education in this field what
are your thoughts on Asian nutrition
always matters and some people are more
sensitive to their nutrition than other
people but what you're eating and
drinking
every day is going to affect the
structure and functioning of your body
sooner or later and the better you get
your nutrition the more you eat what
Eddie knows I like to keep it simple and
the more people eat high quality real
food and the more faithful they avoid
all the fake foods that dominate in our
junk food fast food convenience food
American culture the easier they make it
for their bodies to be healthier and my
intention for for my own health for many
years has been to honor my body to honor
the the miracle of my life the the
wondrous amazing miracle of life with
the best quality food that God nature
have to offer I I was on the other side
of Health for the first 20 years of my
life I was chronically ill I discuss
that and the first time I was on the
Dean show and but at the age of 20 I
woke up to wanting to take
responsibility for my own health and the
only way I knew how to begin to do that
was to educate myself and I began to
educate myself about nutrition and I
applied what I was what I was learning
and after just a week just one week of
some significant improvements as far as
subtracting fake food and eating more
real food I felt better and I felt
significantly better I was able to think
more clearly before I improved my
nutrition I didn't like to read because
I would read something and I would
moment after I read it I forget what I
just read and I'd have to reread over
and over again and I kind of learned to
live in a constant state of brain fog I
didn't see it as brain fog until the fog
started to lift as I improved my my
nutrition and and then eventually over
the years I came to learn that the brain
the brain is the most nutrient sense of
organ of the human body and to this day
when I'm giving people nutrition and
health building guidance I would say at
least four out of five people I work
with will admit to experiencing brain
fog lack of clarity poor memory even
people in their 20s and 30s this is not
older people this is people of all ages
four to five people I work with
will admit to having brain fog to some
extent and like my experience the very
first health benefit I realized from
improving nutrition was the brain fog
started to live and I could think more
clearly and that's what I hear from
almost everybody that I work with to
this day who had some noticeable brain
fog and as they improved their nutrition
even though they may be there their main
goal was to have more energy and to
support healing from some injury or some
other condition they have or maybe they
wanted have a nicer skin or maybe they
just wanted to get rid of chronic aches
and pains have better digestion and
elimination
it's amazing to me and very enjoyable to
hear that almost everybody that I work
with experiences a lifting of the brain
fog to a very significant extent
sometimes dramatically within a week or
two of following their nutrition plan
now how much you guys discussed this at
your at your annual meetings the
community do you guys sit and do you
have a portion dedicated to good health
because we know you know according to
this dean that one of the blessings we
take for granted is our health you guys
talk a lot about health yeah I mean no
we don't actually I don't know we don't
we don't it's not a topic that comes up
very much it comes up very seldom and
you know there is a principle there's a
statement of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him where he said you know Allah
daughter well I'll do it on this
principle comes up a lot which basically
means that there is no causing of harm
and there should be no receiving of harm
to try to avert harm doing harm and from
receiving harm as much as possible so we
kind of use this principle and trying to
decide certain cases and issues that are
presented to us but what we generally
what generally ends up happening is
every
time is a medical issue we kind of look
at it from the Islamic interpretive side
on the text and then we say you know
what whatever medical research is
presented to us or we need to go up you
know call up a local Muslim doctor or
something like that and say hey guy went
to medical school whatever he says we're
gonna take that information that we have
and we're gonna build our fatwa we're
gonna build our verdict or you know our
ruling or what Islam says about it based
upon the information that we're getting
and the problem is sometimes I mean I've
started to realize now that sometimes
the information that we're presented
with is just wrong it's it's it's either
very poor shoddy research or it was just
something that was believed by you know
the medical industry for a very long
time and it turned out that it was not
accurate and we built in an Islamic
ruling upon that and that's obviously
very problematic so we generally don't
talk about it a lot we try to just
outsource it just say you know what just
just go ask your local doctor you know
like you were talking about just the guy
in the lab coat you know so yeah the guy
who has all the answers so that's that's
pretty much what what's happening at the
moment right I walked into a
pediatricians office not too long ago
about a year ago I walked in and I
observed around me a waiting room full
of kids and to my left kids eating
potato chips to my right the kids eat
drinking a coke straight ahead the other
kids eating some cookies and other fake
food but you're bringing your kid there
for an ailment for because he's having a
health issue but right in front of you
you're not address addressing the main
issue what do you think Jim I think
that's that's that's a prime example of
one of the things that's wrong with
modern medicine is that they don't give
any real attention to nutrition's
influence on the body and in medical
school not at all because that's not
part of the business model and this is
one of the things we were talking about
earlier that there's a fundamental
question that that really needs to be
asked to help people have more
understanding about why things are the
way they
are and the question is to ask why are
things the way they are why is modern
medicine practice the way its practice
with such a heavy emphasis on
pharmaceutical drugs and surgical
procedures and and and other practices
that people can't do for themselves and
it's all about what the doctor does for
you what the doctor does to you but they
really don't give any any attention to
empowering people to help you better
know how to take care of yourself now
there are some exceptions there are what
I call some real doctors some real
doctors who do that some real doctors
who actually do teach patients how to
improve their health by improving their
nutrition and the and other aspects of
self-care but that's not what dominates
unfortunately what dominates our medical
doctors who no matter what your problem
is no matter what's going on here's the
solution it's a prescription or it's a
series of prescription drugs and there's
a place for that but there's no drug
that was ever developed that addresses
the cause of any health problem not even
antibiotics you because some people
might say well antibiotics addressed the
cause of a problem because they directly
kill germs that can cause infection but
wait a second human beings have an
immune system your immune system is
supposed to be the main the main
protection against any type of infection
so when someone gets an infection
consider that their immune system was
too weak to do what it needed to do the
immune system got compromised somehow
and antibiotics can certainly kill germs
and and and clear up an infection in the
short run but antibiotics also they have
they have some pretty serious other
effects they can damage your intestinal
ecology kill off friendly bacteria in
your in your intestines and set you up
for
are all kind of intestinal problems
everything from from condition known as
candidiasis which is intestinal yeast
and then fungus overgrowth which causes
problems with digestive distress and in
antibiotics also they they not only they
not only have this adverse effect and
killing the the probiotic friendly
bacteria that everybody needs for
healthy digestive and intestinal health
they also can weaken your own immune
system response you know in my years at
doctor McCullough's clinic we had so
many patients come there who had as
their history in their history recurrent
infections respiratory bladders sinus
infections reap constantly treated with
antibiotics and this would go on for
years with some people you know the
antibiotics we're not addressing the
cause of their problems because it was
only they take the antibiotics and clear
up the infection and then you know a
month later or two months later they get
another infection treated with more
antibiotics consider that this is not
medical science this is a business model
let's hold off we're gonna take a break
very exciting so much to learn we need
the movers and shakers out there we got
one of them so we can get enlightened we
can get in for make the right decisions
the right choices we write book more
here Today Show and don't forget
subscribe right now
back here on the Dean show with chief
nutritionist Jim Marlow it's going on 40
years it's going on 40 years you've been
star we say this and it's not quite yet
you're open I started I started studying
nutrition the age of 20 in 1977 so next
year will be my fortieth year of
studying nutrition and the other
fundamentals of health and I'm going to
continue to study it for as long as I'm
around because there's no end to
learning is no matter how much you know
or how much you think you know there's
no end to learning and I hope to
continue to learn and grow for as long
as I'm around you God willing we can all
do that grow that's the part there's a
great statement talking about you know
intelligent person one part of learning
is is is relearning sometimes you learn
some things and you have to get that out
of your system and relearn the right
information all of us sometimes we are
susceptible today what do you think
about he was saying we know there's a
great misuse of antibiotics yeah today
you know there is benefit in it but
there's a great misuse every time you go
I know myself I get sick give it an anti
anti but then it's time of the
consequence is over misuse and some of
these other things you say what do you
think yeah I mean initially it's
starting to make sense right I've been
looking into this as well but you know
when I first started to hear this in the
beginning the average person thinks hold
on this something doesn't seem right
about how can be how can the entire
industry that we have so much trust in
you know we have so much faith in we we
know so many doctors and they seem like
good people they seem like intelligent
people they seem like people who know
what they're doing they did good in
school in order to get into the medical
school they paid all this money or you
know got some loans you know to do all
of this their goal was to do to do good
so how can this be like some some giant
conspiracy that's taking place you know
that's that that's the initial initial
reaction that takes place until you
start reading more and you start you
know listening so wait a minute this
this could this this he this person may
be on to something and other people may
be on to something you know so that's I
I want I want to you know just I want to
put the questions out there that a lot
of people are gonna be asking themselves
like you know what you're telling me
that these antibiotics and everything
that people are prescribing this has
been going on for decades now
so many people involved it is some kind
of giant conspiracy you know I think
that's an important
to ask we should get like a response to
that are you some kind of conspiracy
theorist now just the truth seeker and a
truth teller as I was saying before a
very important question to ask is why
are things the way they are and when you
you go down that path and you go down
all the way to find the origins of
modern medicine you find that the the
interests that actually had the biggest
influence on modern medicine and why
it's so drug oriented the interest these
are very powerful very wealthy interest
over a hundred years ago that saw
unfortunately it's it's it's kind of
it's it's hard for for people to believe
this if you have if you have a
conscience you have that you have you
have passion or at the very least
respect for truth and and and not lying
and not harming other people that it's
hard for people to understand that there
were very wealthy very powerful
interests at the beginning of the 20th
century who used their their their
wealth their power in their influence to
basically shape a medical system that
would serve their business interest even
more but they saw disease and illness
and even more so the fear of disease and
illness as a marketplace to be exploited
say look this is all documented oh yes
research yes yes I would suggest that
for any anybody viewing this episode of
the Dean show that you go to youtube and
there give you give people a number of
presentations to check out a really good
starting point is a as a presentation by
G Edward Griffin who is an investigative
journalists a truth seeker into through
truth teller he wrote a book in the
1970s called world without cancer and
he's written many books over the years
on other subjects too but he's got a
wonderful presentation from 2005 on
YouTube it's called the science and
politics of cancer and he gets into with
in his presentation
origins of modern medicine and the
people that had the the biggest
influence on the way medicine is
practiced to this day most people don't
ask this question why are things the way
they're most doctors don't ask this
question I have a sister who's a medical
doctor and she went to medical school
with good intentions but she doesn't she
didn't know who was they the dominant
influence on the medical school
curriculum when she went there but she
went through four years of medical
school without one minute of nutrition
it wasn't it wasn't part of her
curriculum how could you go through
Medical School
without having one class or even one
minute giving attention to what people
put into their bodies every day you know
of course what we put into our bodies
every day is going to affect the way we
feel I mean the average person would
assume that this is a naturally part of
the medical school curriculum
how can your doctor not know about
nutrition it's the assumption that they
know everything about the human body and
they know how to take care of it that's
the propaganda that we get you know be
before you before you change your diet
check with your doctor before you take a
vitamin supplement up with your doctor
before you start an exercise program
check with your doctor as if they know
about this they don't learn about how
about the food well III think it was so
appropriate that a pyramid was used to
convey the government dietary guidelines
because ultimately what is a pyramid or
one one of the functions of a pyramid
it's an Egyptian tomb right what an
appropriate structure to use for
conveying dietary guidelines from the
government well what what I mean but
people would say okay but these are the
the the the biggest organizations FDA
CDC these World Health Organization's
that the doctors go back to there's a
consensus on the amount of sugar intake
cholesterol and for a long time I don't
know if it's changed now but we were
thrown out the Hilton over the open and
we eat just the way egg whites so they
were onto something were they but is
that changing now or is it still those
recommend
well there is no one specific
nutritional practice that is going to be
right for everybody for many people the
best part of the egg is the yolk for
other people they do better with just
the white and I think for most people
they do better just eating the whole egg
just to address what you brought up
Eddie but I think we need to we need to
be persistent in addressing the origins
of modern medicine who really shaped the
way modern medicine is to this day and
when you when you when you go down that
path you find out that one of the the
most powerful interests was not a doctor
was not a was not a scientist was not a
researcher but the wealthiest man in the
world at that time the person who was
considered the first billionaire in the
world john d rockefeller he was the man
he and his people they set about taking
over the medical school curriculum and
ultimately using the method be
conventional medical establishment to
serve their business and Trust we're
gonna go ahead and take a break more to
talk about we're talking about the
history now this is very importantly to
get more into them to come back here to
do don't go anywhere and don't forget
subscribe right now
back here on the Dean show let me get
you in on this we were we were we left
off with some of the history well did
you know a lot about this have you know
I mean I I I kind of had some suspicions
that you know what there's obviously an
economic aspect involved in kind of the
medical industry it's it's a very big
industry you make a lot of money you
know keeping people kind of you know
giving them pills and getting them
surgeries and all that stuff there's a
good aspect to you know helping people
but obviously there's there's there's
economic aspects to it and also you know
there's there's conflict of interest
sometimes because you know the goal of a
medical professional the goal of a
doctor is supposed to be to to help the
patients to get wellness to get healthy
you know to get out of the issues that
they have and to maintain a good healthy
body and you know you're able to
function but there is that conflict
between you know what you're a surgeon
you know I want to upgrade my Mercedes
you know I want I want the latest model
if I don't give this guy surgery I'm
gonna be making you know ten thousand
twenty thousand less just add a little
extra surgery in there you know I can
make an extra twenty K throw ten K
whatever it is a little tiny thing you
know someone's going to birth maybe the
baby would have come on naturally to
just go straight to c-section just so
you know we recommend you just go
straight to c-section and the person's
like well you know the guy in the white
lab coat said that so we should go ahead
and do it you can make some extra money
and that's just part of human nature so
I think that the medical industry or
them even than the medical experts
they're not they're not exempt from
these type of you know human frailties
human weaknesses and that's concerning
that's very concerning so we can say we
shouldn't be naive we shouldn't be nice
we we need to question we absolutely
have to question and that's as something
that were taught as Muslims you were
taught in Islam that you know I should
always be searching for the truth in
everything you know so God created us
with the mind for a reason right and
we're supposed to try and find the truth
wherever that truth lies we'd be willing
and open to listen and to kind of hear
away what's going on kind of especially
when you when you when a mistake has
been made in the past you know the
Prophet peace be upon him he actually
said that a believer is not bitten from
the
all twice so once you find out that you
know what if there's a misdiagnosis or
your doctor did something that wasn't
needed to be done or you learn in the
past that you know what some medical
information that was mainstream it was
taught this is absolute fact and then
it's completely overturned ten years
later 20 years later and like I can't
believe they everyone bought into that
idea that that's crazy they they they
thought that this was correct you have
to be a little bit more skeptical so
that you're not bitten from that same
hole twice you got to learn your lesson
yeah that makes sense that's what we're
taught be true seekers URF you were
talking about some more of the history
yeah and and resources for people to
learn for themselves
besides the presentation on the science
and politics of cancer by G Edward
Griffin I also recommend that people
check out a on YouTube a video
presentation from an investigative
journalist by the name of James Corbett
the Corp some people may be familiar
with the Corbett report but he's got a
wonderful wonderfully researched well
researched presentation on Rockefeller
Medicine is what he calls it it's about
a 45-minute presentation on basically
what I brought up a little while ago
about the origins of modern medicine who
was the biggest influence on the medical
school curriculum who's the biggest
influence on the way medicine is
practiced to this day and and I I don't
want to sound I don't want to I won't
don't want people to think that entirely
critical of the whole medical
establishment I think modern medicine is
at their best in urgent care emergency
care immediate care situations trauma
medicine they they can do some some
wondrous things and and and that's where
they're at their best but but that's a
relatively small part of medical care in
this country the vast majority of
medical care is is treating people with
chronic health problems chronic health
prop
degenerative conditions arthritis and
diabetes and you know cancer in heart
disease and neurological conditions like
multiple sclerosis and Parkinson's
disease conditions that ultimately
manifests because too many because of
too many toxins and not enough nutrients
and it's just only a matter of
time before the body begins to
dysfunction and begins to break down
where we dysfunction and where we we
break down that's that's determined by
our individual strengths and weaknesses
and that's there's certainly a genetic
influence there but you know exposure to
toxins like mercury and arsenic might
cause neurological degeneration and one
person immune system damage in another
person you know an ultimately cancer or
heart disease in another person so
there's a spectrum of possibilities
there for how ultimately the
consequences of exposure to
environmental toxins will affect
someone's health but other resources
besides the G Edward Griffin
presentation and and James Corbett and
Rockefeller Medicine Jon Rappoport who
is one of my heroes he's a truth seeker
and a truth teller he's a he's an
investigative journalist especially in
regard to medical issues John Rapoport
has his own website called no more fake
news which I I read almost on a daily
basis but he's got his own presentations
if you google Jon Rappoport and
Rockefeller medicine and CDC fraud FDA
fraud he's written about these issues a
lot and also a doctor by the name of
Matthias Rath he's a german doctor who
has some wonderful presentations he was
he was one of the doctors that ty
Bollinger interviewed extensively in his
series on the truth about cancer and of
course I'm all for people watching the
the ty Bollinger truth about cancer
series especially episode one in which
he addresses exactly what I'm talking
about is why are things the way they are
why is is is is cancer treatment in
America as practiced by the conventional
medical staff why is it's only really
oriented toward the poisons
euphemistically called chemotherapy and
I refuse to just call it chemotherapy
without practicing it with the poisons
euphemistically known as chemotherapy
those drugs are poisons and and
radiation chemo and radiation with no
attention to natural therapies
alternative proven therapies and there's
a lot of information in the marketplace
about that there's a wonderful book by a
researcher consumer patient advocates by
the name of advocate by the name of
Tonya Hart or peer she wrote a book a
number of years ago called outsmart your
cancer which covers natural therapies
for helping people to overcome cancer
that the conventional medical
establishment gives no attention to but
getting back to dr. Matthias Rath is
presentation on YouTube if you just
google dr. Matthias Rath eradicating
heart disease is is is that's that's his
specialty and that that would be a very
good starting point for people to
actually take in information from from
people that have actually learned the
history of the origins of modern
medicine and so I think a lot of people
who go to medical school with very good
intentions and they want to help people
I think their their good intentions are
to a very large extent exploited and and
even betrayed and as far as what they're
learning I mean they're the the
conventional medical establishment is
there's no doubt it's a very it's it's a
huge very expensive infrastructure that
has been built up it's in place and they
need customers no money is generated for
for the the the medical industrial
complex until someone gets sick or
injured and because they don't they only
give lip service to prevention and
promoting health but we really we don't
have any real health care system in this
country you know what it really is if
you think things through logically what
the way things are set up
well we what's called health care in
this country it's really disease
treatment or injury treatment pain
insurance is what is what health care
assurance insurance really is it doesn't
the premiums that people pay on an
ongoing basis it it does very little if
any to any to anything to insure their
health but it's disease and or injury
treatment payment insurance you've been
in a car accident you're you have you've
developed some disease and now it's all
about who's gonna pay the bill how does
that insure your health how is that good
for your health they you know the the
most practical health insurance we could
have is to give faithful attention to
putting the best quality food the best
nourishing ourselves with the best
quality food and and drink that's
available to us and getting the rest of
our self care right because we're giving
faithful attention to other fundamentals
of health our breath the quality of our
breath the quality and quantity of water
we're drinking every day getting a good
night's sleep moving your body moving
activity exercise this is of course a
fundamental level these are some basic
things that key health to key how 50% of
people we talked about cancer will have
cancer 1/3 will die from it so this is
obviously something at these sessions
with other scholars that I think is
something that should be prioritized
yeah well what do you think from what
he's saying yeah I mean it's these are
very important questions that are being
raised I mean we get you know people
want to know okay I got cancer should I
go for chemo I'm kind of scared
I'm kind of scared but you know I'm a
Muslim that what does what does God want
me to do I mean does you want me I got
the money should I go ahead and just do
the chemo because I might be able to
live longer and how does that you know
how does that tie into you know the
decree of God everyone's gonna die at a
certain time anyways or should I go with
something more natural these are
questions that we do need to start
discussing and we we're usually just
getting one side of the story and that
story that side of the story is the
medical professionals in these clinics
so hearing this is is very important I
think for all Muslim scholars to kind of
weigh and say wait a minute maybe we
need to rethink the advice that we
generally given so just well you know
this is beyond this outside of our realm
just go ask your doctor this has
plays a major role as people as human
beings and there's a big difference
between truth and propaganda and my
advice to people is to be very skeptical
about any health information or any
information you hear on disease
treatment from the mainstream media
because the mainstream media is
basically owned by by corporate America
and these interests that are part of the
medical industrial complex
I think the mainstream media television
and radio and newspapers they all are
used to convey the propaganda to the
public promoting that you know America
has the has the best medical care system
in the world and that people should
should should go into the medical
establishment for anything to do with
health but I recently shared with Eddie
something that was was never brought out
in the mainstream media but this is from
this is from one of the most prestigious
medical journals in the world July 26th
edition in the year 2000 of the Journal
of the American Medical Association
there was a comprehensive article
written by dr. Barbara starfield who had
all of the most prestigious medical
establishment credentials and the the
title of her article was is US
healthcare the best in the world and
within that article she stated a number
of facts such as every year as of 2000
as a July 26 2000 year in the United
States at least 225,000 people are
actually killed from medical treatment
and over a hundred thousand people are
killed from taking fda-approved
pharmaceutical drugs as prescribed this
is not people overdosing these are not
mistakes this is people dying from
taking fda-approved drugs as prescribed
again the citation is dr. Barbara
starfield
Journal of the American Medical
Association July 26 2000 the mainstream
media never addressed this in fact
Barbara starfield was interviewed by Jon
Rappoport a number of years after she
published this article and he asked her
were you ever contacted by every any
government agency that's in charge of
you know protecting the public health
the FDA the CDC about your information
and the fact that almost a quarter
million people as of 2000 are it's
acknowledged it's not this is not
controversial almost a quarter million
people are actually being killed by
medical care in this country and she
said no no one had any interest in
looking into this and what can we do to
improve improve medical care so there's
there's less people being killed by
fda-approved drugs so when when you
learn about this and the truth is there
the information is there but if it's not
supportive of the the medical industry
propaganda you don't hear about it at
all or you only hear about it you know
one time and then there's no follow-up
investigation at all but the truth is
there and ultimately we have to be very
careful who we trust what we buy into
and is the is the medical industry is
are they trustworthy is is the FDA
trustworthy is the is the CDC s--
trustworthy or was ralph nader who ran
for president a number of years ago was
was was was he on to something when he
said the real issue about what's going
on in this country is that corporate
america has taken over the government
they've taken over government agencies
and the government agencies which were
originally created to serve public
interests are serving corporate
interests serving very powerful
entrenched business interests we're
almost out of time your last this is
very alarming you know hearing more and
more of this the more I hear it's I mean
Muslims are concerned about people dying
they're concerned about you know the
children in Palestine who are being
the oppression in that area in Syria in
Burma in all different parts but this is
this is just another thing now to add to
the list I mean if people are dying
because of federally approved drugs that
they're taking or medical treatment that
that they're going many people still
have this perception that you know
America is the best place in the world
for healthcare and therefore hey it's
it's better than India or it's better
than you know Nigeria or something like
that so this is the place where you'd
want to be but if we're harming people
and if there's some type of harm going
on or people are even being killed we
have a responsibility as Muslims and we
have a responsibility as Muslim leaders
as well to kind of look into this in
whatever capacity we can and start
asking the questions becoming at least a
little bit more skeptical kind of open
our minds and say you know what someone
does need to investigate this more we do
need more education on this and you know
we need to rethink this entire thing you
mentioned c-section before I have
recommendation for for people who would
like to be more educated about what goes
on in regard to hospital births there
was a wonderful documentary that was
done a number of years ago called the
business of being born you've seen that
yes I strongly recommend that to to all
parents who are about to have a child
but one of the basic lessons of watching
this this very well-done documentary is
that the more medical treatment people
accept the more then they need it's like
the way the way the medical industry is
it's like there's they're very good at
perpetuating more business for them so
much many people have been affected by
this this is a great example of the
c-section you have you know more kids
but now because you've had one or two
now yeah once it once you get one
c-section then you get what's called
VBAC you know a vaginal birth after
c-section and it's very difficult to be
able to have a normal natural birth
after it happens once there's a lot of
you know Muslim sisters in the community
that are saying you know whoa what
should we wear do you draw the line
where do you make the decision between
okay I'm afraid for my child I don't
want my potential child you know it's
kind of becoming out and I want it to be
harmed at the same time it might be more
harmed by going into this procedure so
it's a skyrocket it's like over 50 60
percent so you say so this is another
greatest now we're out of time we only
touched the surface but that's another
great example maybe profits over people
yeah any closing comments for the
audience yeah be confused I think what
do I abandon medical care what I mean do
i it's some people for hearing this for
the first time what advice do you give
yeah I think what I heard from from Jim
made sense is that you know what it's
not about abandoning medical care it's
kind of understanding where it functions
very well and where there's there are
some gray areas and there's some
question marks and we need to kind of
you know reanalyze what our
understanding of medical care is like
you said emergency care and those type
of things generally I mean if someone
breaks the arm or something like that
you would still advise them yeah yeah go
to the doctor don't don't you know start
eating some more nutrition or you know
don't stay at home and say it's just
gonna heal itself you know just just
it's okay so there are aspects where
it's pretty clear-cut right there are
you know some good research out there
there's this good care but then there
are other aspects where there's gray
areas history has told us that we've
made several mistakes and several
u-turns and all of that so my advice to
everyone is just to kind of you know
before dismissing everything as a
conspiracy theory there may be a few
people who are very extreme out there
but you know people who are kind of
knowledgeable they have an understanding
they have research people from within
the system within the medical community
when they're asking the questions we
should be willing to listen we should do
a little bit more research you know
people like you said we shouldn't always
trust the mainstream media we don't you
know more people have woken up they're
not always trusting the mainstream media
for political issues they realize the
corruption in that field the like we're
gonna find alternative avenues right so
so this could very well be something
similar where we need to find alternate
alternate knowledge sources where we can
actually kind of get the real story of
things Jim would you be willing if they
had one of their meetings with some of
the movers and shakers and they wanted
to learn more on this topic would you
come and sit with some of course it's in
this field of course
I'm enthusiastic and glad to share what
I have to offer with anybody who's
interested and in in nutrition and
health truth and and empowering
themselves and other people to know how
to better take care of themselves
you know doctors do have they have have
their the role and they have their place
my my my advice would be for people to
seek out natural medicine doctors
doctors it could be an MD or might be a
do or a nature path but seek out doctors
who actually focus more on promoting
health than treating the symptoms of
disease or illness but there's a lot of
a lot of natural medicine doctors around
not nearly as many as the the doctors
who are little more than legalized drug
pushers especially in regard to chronic
health problems but there are there are
some real doctors around and ultimately
the most important doctor to honor to
respect into support is the doctor
within yourself the innate intelligence
that we all have our body knows how to
be healthy it wants to be healthy it's
always trying to be healthy if we cut
ourselves it heals but it doesn't heal
magically we need to be be getting our
nutrition and our self-care at least
right enough to support the the healing
potential that we all have inside of us
but we all do have an inner doctor and
that's the doctor that I think we should
honor and respect and support most of
all there are you system is powerful is
it from God that he's given us not just
the immune system but but the entire
body the energy the whole body is one
it's that it's it's a we function as a
whole organism and the immune system is
just one part of our biology and when
when you're when you're on a health
building nutrition plan you know
nutrition good nutrition feeds every
cell of your body you know when you take
a drug a drug may have one effect on one
aspect of your biology to suppress a
particular symptom
you know improves a blood test or makes
maybe reduces a symptom a little bit in
the in the short run but it's not good
for your whole body but you know when
you when you eat a truly nourishing meal
it's it you're feeding your brain cells
you're nourishing your your your heart
your liver your kidneys your lungs your
immune system your endocrine system all
of you is getting nourished and you know
as I mentioned in previously that our
approach at the optimal wellness center
dr. Mercola is clinic in the glory days
of the optimal Wellness Center was the
the the approach that we had was really
to teach people how to build their
health through nutrition and the best
way to overcome what you could call the
darkness of disease is to turn on the
light of health beautiful build health
and with that thank you guys so much for
being with us thank you had to go to us
again sometime to future thank you guys
hope you benefit it we'll see you next
time peace be with you selmak and don't
forget subscribe right now